[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so hi everyone thank you for for having
me today so first let me say that I
realized that I may come across as the
party breaker here because everybody's
excited about Big Data and Here I am
talking about the limitations right I'm
hoping that everybody thinks this way
but even if everybody does actually it's
good because I think this is meant to be
kind of thought provoking so it's good
I'm grabbing your attention so my name
is Jennifer and so I'm part of a group
at Walmart Labs called the search
algorithm team and so when you're a data
scientists in retail you know all too
much about Big Data right I mean so you
have lots of different types of data
your your images you have description
styles customer engagement you can get
surveys if you want actually you have
lots of data and probably too much of it
and so we're all there because we're
excited about Big Data
of course and talk about you know Lika
where we are at today why you know Big
Data is exciting but also try to cover
the different kinds of problems you may
come across when working with big data
as a data scientist alright so so I'll
divide my presentation into four
different parts so first I'll you know
like obviously confirm that big data is
on its way it's already there and it
looks like we are going to have to deal
with it
so I'll show how we can do amazing
things with it but then I'll spend some
more time describing what I call the
anatomy of the data set how do you
describe the quality of your data and
the value of your data because I think
it's kind of important to follow the
rest of the talk and then I'd like to
spend some time balancing you know like
a this question that a lot of data
scientists and data engineers have
brought forward what is more important
having more data are having better
algorithms since while I would like to
you know bring a few points over here
and then I actually dig into the
limitation themselves and show you that
even though we're excited there are a
few things we have to be careful about
so let's get started so obviously big
beta is the new norm right I mean a few
years ago I think we considered big data
both word I wouldn't even call that a
buzzword anymore because it's everywhere
right I mean so this is our daily life
as their data experts actually we're
we're in the face of unprecedented
exclude a data explosion right I mean so
I don't know if everyone is aware of
that number but like every one one and a
half to two years we're actually
doubling the size of data we have so
essentially that means that every two
years we are creating as much data as
the rest of humankind before that that
point in time which is kind of amazing
and so why are we creating so much data
now it's not because we're more active
it's because we're more connected now I
mean every single move you're you're
you're making I mean can be recorded by
by a SmartWatch or by any kind of
wearable device and so of course this is
a huge opportunity for industries to you
know Lika try to capture this data and
try to make sense of it and of course
try to monetize on this but let's take
take all of this with a grain of salt so
actually when I say there is an
explosion some of it is actually due to
the fact we're capturing data that we
may not actually need or that can mean
you know like not actually contain any
useful information for us and also among
the data that we capture capture there
is also repeatedly data settings that we
copy over and over again anyhow we're
absolutely data upsets nowadays and that
is for better or for worse so how come
we're seeing such a huge increase of you
know like the amount of data we're
capturing now and so the answer to that
is obviously we have the technology to
do that now right the reason why we
didn't do it before is not necessarily
where we're not not interested it's
simply that we didn't have the means to
do it now we have ways to capture data
in suspected ways and we also have the
diane's science to try to to make sense
of it and process it so a quick fun fact
actually so and so I absolutely had to
that in my in my talk I mean because
this is the kind of information you can
share with your friends and brag about
how much knowledge you have right I mean
so do you think that beta as a weight so
there was actually a person on YouTube
that try to answer that question a while
back and so by actually considering the
fact that data is actually a set of
electrons in motion and by using e
equals mc-squared
you're actually able to compute that the
entire internet in 2005 is the weight of
a strawberry so it's kind of surprising
because it's small it's pretty small but
at the same time it actually shows you
that data as weight and so I actually
realized that this was for the internet
in 2005 I think so because that is
growing I had to refresh that
information and so as for today if you
take all the data in the world I would
actually approximate that to America
about the weight of a watermelon and by
2020 we will use ahead basically the
weight of a person right so why did I
actually you know like share that with
you for for three reasons
one data is tangible it's more tangible
than you think it is the next thing is
that we're growing really fast right I
mean talk about weight gain and so
finally I mean there's still a lot of
room to grow I mean so at the end of the
day it's not it doesn't look like it's
so you tree okay so let's go back to the
technicalities right so we all talked
about growing the amount of data so what
does growing data actually mean right so
obviously as I was mentioning before
this may mean that you may want to
collect data in new ways and collect new
data sets exotic data sets most of the
times this is not what happens what
happens is you're doing exactly the same
thing you just doing it at scale and
you're getting more data more of the
same kinds of data so that's free ways
to do that the first thing is you
actually increase the number of rows
right so for a company like Walmart
getting more rows essentially means
getting more customers and so this
pretty much happens in an organic way
I'm not
anything as the data scientist to get
more data it just happens right I mean
so hopefully marketing is a the reason
why we have more customers but at the
end of the day I'm just waiting for this
data tools to get to me then you can
increase the amount of data by
increasing the number of features right
I mean so so again for Walmart the
number of features may be simply
increasing the number of items because I
consider you know like the the way that
the customer interacts with an item as
as a possible situate or it can also
mean that now I'm trying to instrument
things that I was not interested
instrumenting before so for example if
we start showing ads you also have to
account for the behavior of the customer
when they are interact with these ads so
it can both happen organically or it can
happen because you you want to collect
extra data that you think is meaningful
for the problem you're trying to solve
and then the third way is actually by
increasing density right so I know what
some would say would actually that this
is actually increasing the number of
rows right just to give you an example
if I think of filmography increasing the
number of rows would actually be looking
at a longer clip or a longer movie rate
increasing density is actually
increasing the number of pictures per
per second and so there is a notion of
like acting faster right so again for
more modest we mean that I may want to
be more involved with the customer we
used to look at the the the way the
customer is entering a query and the
quote on on the search box just at the
moment they actually enter our search
and you don't know what happens before
now because we're entering in these
feeds of the data we have an opportunity
to actually see how quickly they're
typing how many times they change their
mind and this kind of things so at the
end of the day when you grow the you
know you grow data in all the directions
and so if you increase the number of
rows your ability expecting to have a
scalable model right and you take the
same models you're trying to make them
more scalable if you increase the number
of features you will actually want to
build a new model if you increase
density you're expecting to handle your
data at a faster speed and reach a less
where your models are real time right I
mean actually to able to make decision
in real time and so it's actually it
might be more than you bargained for
because it's a lot of work for the data
science community right I mean you have
to improve your existing models change
your models think of new ways of
capturing and faster way of processing
so it's both an opportunity but it's
also a liability all right so so there
we are today right in there are many
areas that collect more data and that
needed a lot of data so that we can
actually make progress for example in
research medicine communication robotics
and so forth and so on right and so much
data is coming at us it's both exciting
but it's also mind-boggling
so before we make a judgement call on
whether we want this data or not or if
this data is good I like to spend much
more time explaining what's new like how
you measure the quality of your data so
why did I use the word Anatomy here so
this is because I think that usually
when you think of data you think of data
as an entity as a very concept you don't
necessarily think of it as an object
that you can actually go and study with
precision and as the data scientist that
doesn't make me feel good I mean it
essentially says that if data is just a
concept I the data is actually handling
me I'm not handling the data right I
mean so I think the fact that you can
actually precisely describe your data
gives you a feeling of control that the
data scientists today have to have so so
it actually sounds pretty complicated
like put numbers on your data and
validate quality anyone who's tried to
do to do it actually knows how
complicated it is just just to think
about it anyone who's ever worked with
the data said that has more more than 10
features and let's say a thousand rows
we know how completed it complicated it
is wait I mean so the reason for that is
as humans we are attracted by things
that we can visualize so 10 features
doesn't seem like a lot from a big data
point of view but it's already too much
for the human brain to be able to
process easily so you essentially can
describe your data and the quality of
your data through three different are
things that need to be accomplished
right and so there is the concept of
sanity become concept of completeness
and the concept of richness so I'll
explain this concept in just a minute
just so that you realize already right I
mean so getting like a very good
understanding of how valuable and how
good your data is is actually something
that requires a lot of work a lot of
discipline a lot of time the
collaboration of multiple teams and
probably the health of artificial
intelligence in the future okay so so
there is a structural aspect to the
quality of the data right and so there
is a concept that you call integrity
right and so if you look at your
integrity would be something like when I
have a specific role that I expect to be
in you know like a specific types of
data or specific format updates I expect
the same kind of you know like a
formatting across the entire data set
now if somebody changes that convention
are anything happens or there is a
migration of something and different
people are not careful this is easily
broken and you would be surprised like
how many data sets actually don't even
fulfill that that aspect of things the
other thing is validity for validity is
about the variables being in a specific
range so first of all I don't want to
have any crazy values most of the time
my values are between minus 10 and 10 I
don't want to see you know like many
values are close to 100 but it also mean
it's also more important when you're
dealing for example with the
probabilities I mean it probability by
the definition is supposed to be between
0 and 1 and has to say between 0 and 1
for the sanity of the algorithm you're
going to build on this so I mean it's
really important to make sure that you
keep the same conventions and formula
and run your data on the same systems
over over time the next thing is a the
aspect of self consistency so
self-consistency happens I mean it is
important when you work with feature
engineering so we all know that we'd be
sometimes don't like to use
exactly the data as it is coming and you
want to pass process it right I mean and
we know that to be a very efficient way
to make our models work better and so if
you if you use a specific formula to
compute a new column it has to be you
have to understand the same formula and
you have to be certain of what that is
right and so you may have problems in
such consistency for example as part of
the data is processed on one system and
another part of the data is processed
somewhere else so this is where the
other process of validation is really
important this is extremely important
because it is extremely difficult to
diagnose after the fact by a position
with a validity and an integrated before
and then you have the problem of n/a is
written into missing missing vada points
everyone that has worked with this kind
of firm knows how annoying it is so we
know that we can try to replace that by
a result value but something that some
kind of fuzzy logic matching and try to
fill these different holes but of course
it's not real leader so we don't know
how well it's performing and we don't
necessarily understand the biases we're
going to get from that but this is not
the biggest problem the biggest problem
action comes where and if you actually
miss an entire row and so for us online
retailers that would very easily happen
if the Add to Cart button is broken for
a specific set of items and we remain
not realize it right away because it's
possible that nobody I mean it's going
to trigger an alarm if it's been like
several hours nobody's buying a specific
item that is popular if the item is not
popular it may take us a very long time
to actually figure that out and so when
you actually figure it out there is no
way of fixing it you essentially have to
discard the data so it's really
important to be sure that this doesn't
happen and then finally you have you
have another aspect of things which you
know like happens where your data is
really keen it's really good it looks
like everything's perfect the values are
filled and using the format's all right
but you may
have info interesting information or
meaningful information in this data set
and so you would have a situation like
this where you have lots of noise many
of this column as rows have exactly the
same entries it doesn't look like I'm
going to be able to use a lot of these
data to do modeling the problem with
that is that depends on the problem I'm
trying to solve if I'm trying to build a
an anomaly detection system it may be
exactly what I need to see right and so
there is a definite difference between
making the data cleaner and making the
data good I mean you can have very clean
datasets that actually don't have any
quality like values that you can use at
a data scientist so I think it's the
right time now to speak about entropy so
entropy is actually the level of
randomness to Havana in a data set so
randomness is good because you want to
have like a sufficient amount of
information uncertainty is essentially
defined by I mean it's essentially null
if you always have the same value I mean
you've seen these data sets where you
always have the same value it doesn't
mean it doesn't seem that you have any
discriminative power within one of the
of the values so maybe it's not forced
collecting that specific value it's
actually wasting space so people are
sometimes confused between values of the
difference between variance and entropy
and so let's try to acquire clarify
right and so obviously both of them try
to measure the level of information and
randomness that exists in the data set
entropy is really about how I mean how
balanced the different values are in my
in a specific data set so the highest
entropy would be reached in a situation
where you only have two outcomes but I
mean the data is essentially balanced
this is very interesting when you are
trying to build classifiers on the other
hand if you want to build you know like
a some kind of a predictor or something
where you actually need to measure the
the the precision of your predictor you
actually need to look at variance
because variance gives you an
information of how spread the values
within the data set are
okay so so basically I mean the question
here is a so what do i what do I want to
have a data set that has a lot of
entropy hardware you don't I want
entropy right and so the problem is
every data every signal is actually
computed by a data which is actual
signal which I am looking for and a
noise component and so I want the signal
to have as much entropy as possible
because this is where the information
the discriminative power of my data is
going to leave at the same time I don't
want too much entropy in the in the
noise part and the problem again like
the notion of noise is problem dependent
so it doesn't look like you can actually
do something in advance it looks like
this is something you have to take care
on a case-by-case basis we want on from
P at the at the signal level and we
don't want them to appear at the noise
level essentially so let's try to define
the notion of information content right
I mean so here I have this toy example
where I have this officiates and each
one can come in into one of the one one
of three flavors right there in three
colors and so the notion of capacity of
storage is essentially like three bits
right I mean because here here I don't
have like a binary information but
essentially you need these three shapes
to be able to define your entire your fa
events your entire row and so the actual
quantity of information is smaller than
this because it has to be contained so
the capacity of storage is in some sense
the price I have to pay to be able to
record that information whether that
information actually has value is not
clear at this point so there is there is
a an algorithm in data mining that
actually uses that information and this
is that a decision trees so this is when
trees work by looking at you like
successive variables and they try to see
whether once you actually studied
variable a do you still have meaningful
information that allows you to separate
your data and classify your data just by
looking at variable B right and so you
do that in this excessive way and it's
very possible that
if you have a very large number of
features you're just going to have a
very small number of Nitra features that
helps you discriminate on the data and
make a decision so just just to give you
a quick example right I mean so you will
have these two data sets here and so
both of them look like they have a lot
of entropy and variance so for each one
of them but the one on the right
actually has a bit of a problem because
you have exactly the same values for the
second row and the third row so
essentially the third row is 100%
described by my second row so
essentially I'm not interested in that
information I completely wasted this
cone right I mean so and it's this will
typically happen in situations where the
mutual mutual information is a is not
good and the correlation is really high
so in the same way that variance and
entropy kind of you know like describe
this in the same idea of silica in
uncertainty I mean you also have the
same kind of relationship between
correlation and mutual information
correlation is a definite idiomatic on
how how two variables actually express
the same information item in so we also
often think of correlation in the linear
way because everybody's used of thinking
of the person Pearson correlation
coefficient but but it's actually I can
actually a nonlinear correlation as well
right and so we have a weird relation
with correlation because we want
correlation because otherwise we cannot
predict anything if there are no
correlations between your output and
your your input variables essentially it
means that everything is noise I mean I
don't have any friction that they
actually use to build a predictive model
but we don't like to have so many
correlations because we have to handle
these in the in the data and they also
waste in place space so it's it I mean
in this sense it's important before I
start building a model to try to
understand whether I have too much
mutual information it's essentially like
most of my variables to enslave the same
idea and by looking at variable V I have
a little information compared to
variable a
this may be something I don't want to
include in my model so I think we're
beta as a as a single unit but in large
companies you have to think of data as a
in terms of an ecosystem and so there
this is a common problem in many
companies right I mean so you have this
master data that someone generates and
captures and then different departments
would like to access the same data and
use them on their you know like a for
their own purposes so they keep copying
that and so over time you have this you
know like a degradation that happens and
and so essentially you get something
that's completely different from what
you had first it is very difficult to
see which one is actually the most
accurate one so it's it's something that
is going to have a lot of value for
companies like like mine and many others
to actually have one place which will
you call the day knowledge that actually
contains the freshest data why is it
important because you need less
engineers you have less probabilities of
making a mistake and it's easier to go
and fix something it's also cheaper
because you can have the same you like
your spark can actually leave in this
area and you don't have to duplicate
like multiple instances of the same of
the same programs and the same software
just like the I mean so these you would
actually call the tough silos if you
actually separate that so this is just
as the interest and as bad as our people
silos in large companies so at the end
of the day what is good data right I
mean so we've seen it seem like there
are some numbers you can prove around it
and some metrics but at the same time
it's not really easy to really get a
sense and be able to say like this is
good data I'm ready to use that the
takeaway is you know it's important to
curate data on its own it's also
important to think of data in terms of
an ecosystem and while data data quality
is absolute value is actually contextual
to the problem you're trying to solve so
let's switch gears a little bit
and you know talk about why algorithms
matter so all right okay so so we've
seen an increase like in the recent
years of algorithms we call that a
greedy algorithm because essentially to
function the
need a lot of data and determining is
the perfect example for that so why are
determining specialists excited about
data so for very one simple reason there
is a statistical benefit from having
more data you're just making the
statistical errors smaller and so but
the varies baseball so I mean this would
happen with any algorithm the reason why
for deep learning big data matters is
actually you have lots of parameters and
so it's very easy I don't know if you
see the shape of that really well but
basically the more parameters are going
to happen the more local minima you're
gonna have and it's very easy for the
model to actually fall into in this one
of the minima through your gradient
descent process and so you would have a
situation where you have a bias in your
model and so many specialists actually
hope that if you keep increasing the
amount of data you would actually have a
convex shape for which it's very easy to
you know find this one pollution and
actually always converge to the bottom
of that it is not clear whether this is
going to happen I mean this is a very
exciting time for deep learning
researchers because we're just at the
phase were here right I mean by this
plane we're we're soon going to see
whether deep learning actually solve all
our problems just by showing more data
at it so I started talking about a
system of statistical error so let's try
to define that a little bit bit so when
you talk about the goodness of the
correctness of a model you actually have
to think you have to look at us
precision and you have accuracy so
precision is about how how well I mean
how precisely and nor in other terms how
how can I put it become essentially how
sure you are that you're getting the
right results accuracy is about how true
your result is and so both are really
important to get a good model there is
actually a notion of trade-off between
these two and so this is expressed
essentially by the fact that you get
high variance when your model is too
complicated and you actually are seeking
out the day on the data or you have a
high bias when
you have not enough parameters in your
data so essentially that means that more
data is obviously going to help your
precision but it's not that clear for
accuracy rate because it may be due to
other things like a data imperfection
problem or it may be that your model is
too simplistic and you actually need to
for more features and more more
parameters at it okay so there are many
reasons how you like basically many ways
for you to fix a model and so so these
are actually like the eight typical
things you would do to go fix a model
and out of this there is one that
actually explicitly says that you want
to throw more data the others are
essentially transforming your data
trying to do multiple algorithm at the
same time and so at the end of the day
big data is important but maybe better
algorithm and working on your algorithm
is just as important so these are a few
genomica questions that you may have
today that we are so excited about data
but at the same time there are there are
many reasons why you you you may want
you may ask yourselves why we actually
need that right so data visualization we
we love this realization because it's
actually trying to trim some data so
that we can actually see the interesting
part of it so while we're we're shipping
data we're also appealed by these
situations where you can actually get a
sense of what your data is right gum and
knowledge domain knowledge is something
that all recruiters when they're
actually looking for data scientists are
actually are killed by having someone or
you like for example Walmart is
interested to have data scientist that I
have experience in read a if you just
throw more data in your models and your
models keep performing better why would
you need that good and then you're like
ah there are other considerations like
um I mean Occam's razor is about getting
things simpler do you actually need more
data to do that and so forth and so on
right and so I'm not going to go through
everything all right so let's dig into
the last part the actual limitations of
big data so the first thing is so if you
look at this example here it I mean so
you may have a data set where you had
exactly two
exactly identical growth and so if I
build a predictive model on this I will
actually predict exactly the same value
right
and it's possible that if I make sure it
predicting the future I can actually go
to check whether I was right or wrong
and and it is possible I'm going to find
something entirely different as you see
on the right and statistically it's not
impossible that you would find something
so far away from the prediction just
because of you know statistics but if I
keep looking at the distribution and
find something I'm like on the top right
then I may start wondering you're like
how is mother able to predict like there
are actually two different kicks on the
on the distribution and this is maybe
because you're not capturing the right
data so essentially it doesn't matter
how well you you model I mean I could
have kept modeling for you know days and
days and still get the same situation
where I just don't get the information I
really need to build my predictor and
get something that actually works
sometimes less is more I think so I
think this diners love to use the
sentence lesson more but I think as they
defined this is no success something you
would think of there is actually I mean
if you look at this curve here so this
is something that psychologists define
as being the inverted you model so
essentially when you put pressure on
people they stop performing well right
when you don't put enough pressure
because there there's not enough stress
they get bored so the optimal
functionality for people and in the time
they actually perform best is actually
somewhere in the middle if you play the
exact same I am you know like an
approach to a data scientist you're
going to get the same thing and so
actually it's very frequent that by
getting more data I mean we have
scientists actually getting this you
know like embarrassment of choices kind
of situation and actually the model
stops I mean they stopped being as
performance then there is another like
psychological algorithm argument you
could think of so I mean this is like
basically this a exponential curve over
there is the way that our memory
functions so when you relearn something
we lose it really quickly right I mean
and so
there's this a psychologist a being
house that actually discovered that you
know they have this relationship that
you want to review the same information
several times because you before you can
actually keep it and remind it on the
very long-term and so this is the how we
function when you are preparing for
exams and so forty things pretty much
the same thing I mean if you have this
nice chunk of data and you're actually
never reviewing it and in the sense that
nobody using it then it's going to get
last frightening people are going to
stop what I mean you're going to have um
so is moving away you're going to have
like this documentation is not good
nobody's gonna remember what that is
it's going to get it like a you know
completely lost at some points so there
is a notion of even if you have really
good data and you are not using it
you're essentially this you need died
over time alright so and then there's
the notion of paralyzation so for me
like big data makes me really nervous
for one reason how am I going to process
so much more data than what I have
already today and people always answer
parallelization
unfortunately parallelization is not
infinite rating so there is this law
called angles law that gives you a sense
of how far we can actually push
paralyzation and so just to give you a
sense rate and switch it really depends
like how how how what is the portion of
your test that you can actually paralyze
but you also have a communication test
that makes things you know like a slower
when you actually combine everything
back into one answer and so if you have
like 95% of your test that is that you
can parallel eyes you can actually only
speed your test by a factor of 20 so you
cannot do that okay you're going to keep
doing that infinitely eyes and so this
is you know basically the cost of the
grader so I think people are just like
there's I mean we are going to have so
much more data to handle but at the same
time are instances as cheaper memories
cheaper CPUs cheaper and this is
actually true I mean is really going
down really really really quickly and
the amount of data we can process is
going up but actually the numbers are
kind of against us because if you look
at the growth of
the storage market so it's going up like
they need you know five to ten percent
the actual demand in storage is going up
by fifty percent so I mean we're
actually not really following the the
amount of similar memory storage and CP
or that we're going to need so we may
soon hit the wall where we're going to
have to read you know like up spend much
more money to actually be able to to
handle all the data that we need and so
as theta scientists we're not trained to
think of data in terms of money but I
mean at the end of the day that's our
job right anymore we're in companies to
actually make money to the company and
make sure that we can help them process
the data and monetize on the data so
this kind of a this kind of questions is
going to be very important for us to
solve so in big data really the future
there are two really big problems that I
see coming at us one thing is that there
is a problem with labeling I can get
lots of data but a lot of the data that
we're using in retailing and I know it's
true of many other places actually some
of it has to be manually processed and
manually labeled and so this is a very
expensive very time-consuming proper
process and it's also like very
error-prone right I mean so if you want
to use the entire in the context of a
supervised machine learning algorithm
then we're going to have us to find a
solution for this the other thing is
that deep learning models are kind of
what we're hoping to be the next
generation of algorithm but deep
learning actually needs so much data
because they are very slow learning
algorithms it takes a lot of data to
train them because they give a very long
memory right and so once they are
confused by something it's actually very
difficult to erase this part of their
memory so essentially we have problems
where we need thousands of images of the
dog to actually teach a computer that
this specific image is resolved when you
shall find pictures of the dog through
toddler for a baby they're not going to
be able to make the difference and so
there is actually a new class of
algorithm called
one-shot learning that actually helped
us solve this problem we're actually
able to replicate the way that babies
learn and so they they don't need a lot
of data so if this algorithm starts
performing as well
like learning why do we actually need so
much data it's possible that after all
we're not going to need as much data as
we think we do so at the end of the day
I mean a big piece that alone is not
enough right I mean it's really like a
place where you have to combine
technology with mathematics the capacity
of visualizing something and analyzing
something from you know like as we do as
humans and also rationality right and so
I don't think we're at the stage where
we can say that artificial intelligence
is going to be able to replace human
reasoning and remo really human you know
like a you know like a rationality of
course I so let's wrap up right I mean
so this is what I really hope that you
will remember from this talk right I
mean so we sure do love our data and it
looks like we're going to have to figure
a lot a lot of things as we grow our
people success is going to go through
being really careful with our date I
mean like a date I need love I need to
be process and needs to it investment to
actually like a be maintained in a good
in a in a good state over time being
methodical is really important we used
to have a we used to define data in
terms of the Seavey's but actually I
think that like the annual like now
we're thinking of the the 70s and so one
thing that is really important is value
right I mean so if you keep having more
data but you're just copying the same
information over and over again then
then maybe we don't have as much data as
we think we do at if we don't have as
much information the internal question
between your like what is more important
is it data or is it the quality of
algorithms I think it's completely
pointless because at the end of the day
they I mean algorithm are pretty much
the found steroids
even that the data is in the shape that
it should be in so more designs coming
at us and I think we have to get ready
for it and be careful what you ask for
at the end of the day more day size good
but better data is best alright so I
just finished with this quote from from
goat so actually both content and met
the method so the algorithm
matter for us to be successful alright
thank you so much perfume for a few
questions how did you get the data on
like the psychological impact of having
more data so I mean this is this is I
mean for what do you like us so this is
especially genomica my experience as a
data scientist rate I mean I at at
format actually saw that our design
engineers were always like very eager to
bring us more data and at the end of the
day you really did see that I mean at
least personally as a data scientist I
was struggling you know like I have so
much data and I like how do I get
started and so that actually involves an
extra process where you actually have to
freak in your data and remove what you
think is useless and unfortunately
sometimes I mean most times like what
you remove is because it's less is
essentially the new features that just
threw in with the hope that it was going
to give you such a you know like a
powerful kind of thing so I mean I'm
just trigger the question at some point
that is it possible that milites the
same kind of you like at the end of the
day we're humans rhythm so data
scientists is still like going through
human reasoning and you're going to have
the same psychological factors when you
work as a data scientist